was that easy to get all the guys to say
yes to come on the show
yeah definitely um you know it was we
talk
every week all five all of you
oh yeah yeah definitely yeah um
so you know and this quarantine has kind
of brought us even closer because you
know you're
you spend more time you know in your
group text and all that
uh but yeah i mean when i wanted to do
something special for the anniversary um
i called you guys like hey let me just
do one-on-one
hard-hitting interviews with each one of
you individually because
i haven't been able to do that as long
as i've been hosting radio and all that
i've never interviewed all all four guys
before
um and so it was it's very special
it went very long i felt bad i mean
there was i think justin's interview
went for an hour and a half
um that's not long at some of these
interviews some people have three hours
rogan three hours i'm like i i want this
to be an hour i'm looking at the clock
now i go i could talk to lance
forever but like an hour hour and 15
that's like that's the
i don't want to talk that long i can't
yeah this day and age people like you
know
small bikes i mean even an hour is too
long for people but yeah i like it
i like to keep my show under an hour um
but it's so
difficult when you have a great yes
yeah and like danny trejo was on my show
this weekend and
he's just he has such incredible stories
he has such a colorful life
like it just went on forever because i
couldn't stop i couldn't not talk about
some of the things i wanted to talk
about
so i have to interview him you know i
met him a couple of times he's like hey
man take my number
and then i was like okay but i never
called him i think i still have danny
he won't even remember
tacos and donuts oh yeah i've eaten them
you know
you go way back you remember i remember
hearing you know you were really upset
you were crushed you were devastated
when justin like left and blah blah blah
and all that stuff and then you
rekindled and you were fine and
everything's great
right in a nutshell oh yeah me and the
guys were never
on bad terms at all it's just you know
life goes on and you you know you have
more interest and you have to focus on
your careers and it's great
uh the thing i was most disappointed in
was not just justin leaving the band
um it's that our whole team our record
label our management everything like
that
they all knew they all knew it was it
was over
for three years and you didn't before
before they told me
and so for three years i'm sitting there
getting ready for a new album
as everyone else knows we're moving on
and so i didn't get i turned down you
know i had a sitcom i was doing had to
turn it down
uh i mean that's all kinds of stuff that
i really wanted to
do and focus on but i knew i couldn't
because you know i'm
my first commitment was instinct like
this is my life you could have been
writing you could have been doing well i
mean you were sure you're writing but
you could have been like doing other
you know going out yeah it would have
been nice to kind of you know
set up a little better before you know
going out solo were you guys
i mean you had to get annoyed i get
annoyed with my brother all the time
when you're on the road
together who was the one guy that you
were just like oh my god
[ __ ] off i mean there had to be those
moments where you're like
you can't love you dove everybody you
had to get little things or like oh yeah
well that's the thing with you know with
us and that's why we're so close we're
brothers i mean we
love each other we hate each other every
single emotion comes
out when you're in a brother
relationship um so yeah
many times that the good thing about us
is if we fight
we make up very quickly like we we kind
of forget things
because i think we're just guys but like
just we we don't hold on to things
too much but the one that would always
uh
make my eyes roll would uh would be
christopher patrick
in interviews uh because chris you know
he's very animated and he's funny and
he's always cracking a joke
but when someone is always cracking the
joke in every single interview
like they do 20 a day and there's five
guys
your days get long and long and long so
there'll be many times i'm like just
shut
up like just answer the questions so we
can move on because we're so tired right
now so
he would always yeah make all our
interviews at least double the time
what was the biggest blowout you could
remember where all five or you were just
like [ __ ] off i don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm with him you're with it that you're
just going back i don't know
we never had that situation i don't
think we have the time to have that
one happen no i mean we never i remember
this one time
the the biggest fight i ever saw um
you couldn't even call it a real fight
we were in miami doing challenge for the
children our charity
uh fighting that we do
and uh we were getting ready we were so
tired because we had been out the night
before and it's just like a whole
three-day event
and um we have to do press the next more
so we're all up in
the hotel room and we're all meeting
there and then we're going to go down
and do all the press
um and then joy was late like he was
about 15 minutes late
you know we're all tired all right and
they had sent food
you know from room service in so we had
all this room service food like burgers
and all that type of stuff
and we're eating and joey had ordered a
burger um well justin as a joke
took the burger and took a huge bite of
it and put it back right
holy moly there was something up joey's
butt that day because when he came in
and he saw someone bit his hamburger
he was like not doing it and he like
protested i i'm not leaving here until i
get a new burger
it was like it was so funny i've never
seen joey get so upset about something
like that but
you could tell he was probably tired or
something he was just over it at that
moment he's like nope
it is you know i'm going to stand on
this crown and i am not leaving here
until
burger gets here so we always we make
fun of him
all the time for that outburst all the
time does anybody did anybody then go
come on dude seriously dude it's a
[ __ ] burger come on
did it start getting heated we're like
you're really gonna make it no
this is disrespect somebody ate my
burger i
[ __ ] it that's how it happened it just
blew up